Disney movies are funny but sometimes
they have a totally different meaning
when you rewatch them as an adult wait
until you hear about the very first
Disney joke of its kind in a very
unexpected movie if you love Disney make
sure to subscribe to the things and give
this video a big thumbs up now let's
check out the 20 adult jokes in Disney
movies you never understood as a kid too
familiar with vegetables
remember that vegetables joke from
ratatouille it happens when Skinner
finds Remy in the pantry and asks him
what he's doing they're trying to get
away with it
Remy stutters and says he's just trying
to get familiar with the vegetables so
he'll know what he's doing in the
kitchen
poor Remy is totally scared of Skinner
Skinner of course yells at him and when
the pantry door closes you can hear
Skinner's say that one can get too
familiar with vegetables do you know
what he meant
the adults probably got a good chuckle
out of this one and it's also crazy to
believe that these words came out of the
mouth of a Disney character the
narcissist joke this joke comes from
Hercules we've all heard of the term god
complex
but Greek mythology does actually have a
God whose name translates into this
complex remember when Hermes said that
he hasn't seen this much love in a room
since narcissus discovered himself well
God narcissus gave the name to
narcissism a personality disorder that
is strongly connected to a god complex
narcissism is all about thinking you
know everything and having a
self-righteous attitude and you can
imagine what kind of self-love Hermes
was talking about with that narcissus
joke it looks like this Greek god really
did enjoy discovering himself didn't he
out of his problems no child should ever
hear about Oedipus or know what that is
but if you saw Hercules there's a good
chance you did it just probably went
over your head let's just say that
Oedipus was a God that took it way too
far
and kept it all in the family if you
know what we mean
Hercules mentioned they edit this play
and said that he thought he had problems
but watching Oedipus made him realize
how normal he actually was if you know
the crazy story behind this Greek god
this sentence will probably make more
sense
buzz reaction okay this is a pretty
shocking one even for Disney it's a
sneaky moment but thankfully most kids
didn't really know what was happening at
least we hope they didn't you know
Jessie from Toy Story right do you
remember what happened to in Buzz
Lightyear first saw Jessie adults have
probably seen that moment as something
completely different than kids did
budget swings raised up the moment he
saw Jessie and there were plenty of
adults that speculate buzz got really
excited if you're still a kid watching
this move along there's nothing to see
here
top-down truck stop okay this one is
really unexpected not even car movies
are safe from Disney's inappropriate
jokes this one is pretty sneaky and not
noticeable unless you saw real-life
signs
similar to this one this sign says that
this is a top-down truck stop and it
comes with all convertible waitresses
it's a very subtle joke but the top-down
kind of gives it away
of course cars having a top down isn't
that controversial but think of it in a
different way
have the convertible waitress and there
you have it a little bit too much isn't
it tiny little problem we're not even
close to being done with the adult jokes
there's another ratatouille scene that
comes off as pretty subtle but we bet
most adults were able to see the humor
in it linguine is trying really hard to
tell Colet about chef remi but he just
can't he ends up almost admitting that
he loves her and then goes on to say
that he has something that's sort of
disturbing he continues to stutter
saying he has something tiny and little
which makes Colette look down and you
know where she looks seriously how many
in new windows does this movie have the
moving earth Aladdin has plenty of
innuendos but one of our favorite one
happens in Aladdin and the king of fees
this joke probably flew over our radar
when we were kids because most of us
probably didn't even know what it means
to go on a honeymoon when Aladdin
jasmine have a wedding you can see the
ground shaking genie makes a remark that
the earth wasn't supposed to move until
the honeymoon the movie nurse and the
honeymoon put together we're pretty sure
most adults were able to figure out what
genie was hinting at and we kind of wish
he didn't foot size these jokes never
ends
even frozen wasn't exactly safe from
extremely subtle and new windows talking
about the size of your feed might not
mean much when you're a kid but every
adult knows the hidden and kinds of
inappropriate meaning behind the length
of your feet
remember when Kristoff asked Anna about
Hans he wanted to know his foot size to
which honor applies but the size of your
feet doesn't matter when you're an adult
the sentence that size doesn't matter
has a different meaning add the feet and
you can really make an inappropriate
moment out of it a busy boy we're
surprised this wouldn't even made it
through because it's pretty awful when
you think about it
101 Dalmatians made us ask plenty of why
questions when it comes to karela de Vil
but it looks like Roger wasn't so
innocent either remember when Roger told
Cruella that Anita's pregnant he then
said they're having puppies - corella of
course then told Roger that he's
definitely been a busy boy pretty sure
karela implied that Anita was also
pregnant with puppies as well as babies
and Roger was definitely busy if you
know what she means chased out of all
Disney movies you definitely need to
re-watch Aladdin because a lot of
Christine's will make a lot more sense
when you're an adult remember the part
where she gets chased through the
women-only house those are some pretty
gorgeous ladies adults will chuckle when
they realize that he's being chased
because he wants to use certain services
in that house without actually paying
for them because he's too poor yep those
ladies offer the oldest profession in
the world it's a very subtle reference
but we're pretty sure most adults were
able to see a different meaning to this
scene pollination no Disney movie is
safe from a new windows but the good
news is they'll only make sense when you
grow up a bug's life is one of those
movies - in the same scene you can see
two fleas catcalling Francis in case
you're not familiar with the term
catcalling is when people whistle or
yell something suggestive and
inappropriate after a person mostly
women in this case the two male fleas
call her a cutie and ask her if she's
like to pollinate with a real bug
it's a bug version of what a lot of
women go through every day and we all
know what pollination actually means
don't we pitching a tent
here's a Disney movie
never really talked about we don't even
give enough credit to the hilarious
movie that is the Emperor's New Groove
but it's actually one of the best Disney
movies ever we watch it as an adult and
pay attention to the moment where Kronk
falls asleep outside holding his teddy
bear
check out that small tent placed on his
body if you're an adult you probably
don't need any other explanation why
this scene is much more hilarious and
far more inappropriate than it should be
seriously this is a bit too much even
for Disney it's in the stars can you
feel the love tonight we kind of wish we
didn't The Lion King has plenty of
hidden moments but one of the biggest
ones is actually written in the stars
you probably know what we're talking
about right this observation actually
originally first came from a little kid
but for the majority of the time it went
unnoticed
remember when Simba Pumbaa and Timon lie
on their backs and look at the stars
Simba goes up to the edge of the cliff
lies down and raises up some dust the
dust turns into three letters and
they're actually pretty shocking
by the way Disney argues that the E is
actually an F but we're not buying its
lemonparty have you ever heard of this
term it's a meme from 2002 that's
usually used as a clickbait or so-called
trolling similar to what people do with
the Rick and roll if you've spent a
while on the internet you've probably
seen it but do you know that the scene
was sort of recreated in cars too it
starts with the lemons a group of
jealous old cars who throw a party with
lemons a lemon party they gave
old-school Internet users a pretty good
chuckle and a slightly nostalgic moment
with an element of surprise because
you'd never expect a lemon party in cars
to flashing cars has another moment with
a pre subtle adult joke you probably
missed you've probably heard the term
groupies right remember the moment when
lightning McQueen gets his big win two
female fans rushed to him and say
they're his biggest fans and then they
flash him with their headlights but
luckily most kids thought the two cars
were just taking a picture of their Idol
it's a solid reminder that Disney can
sneak in an adult joke in just about any
there is eyes up here we're giving a
special mention to the minions even
though they're not a Disney product we
all know that minions can be pretty
raunchy and if you pay close attention
as an adult you'll notice a huge
difference in how you've been perceiving
these jokes in the minion movie you can
see the minions try to access the Tower
of London in their true style they try
to of course stay on top of each other
to dress as a woman right in front of
the tower you see a Frenchman staring at
the bottom minions eyes if you know what
we mean
it seems that the eyes are up here
problem never goes away not even in the
minion world good at multiplying
speaking of Disney movies being never
mentioned to topia is also one of those
underrated movies a lot of adults will
laugh at when they realize just how many
hidden jokes you can actually find it's
amazing to see that they can make a
movie for kids at the same time as they
can make the same movie for adults
remember when Judy Hopps calls out Nick
wilds tax evasion and says that bunnies
are good at multiplying sure she might
talk about math and taxes but we all
know what she's really referring to
leaving you alone we have to give an
honorable mention to one of the jokes
that are pretty subtle but too good to
never mention do you remember the scene
where Jane was drawing Tarzan and gushed
over his eyes her dad noticed it and
thought he'd throw in a subtle jokes
most parents probably understood better
than kids he ends up asking her if Jane
wants to be left alone with her drawing
of the gorgeous Tarzan if you know what
he means
seriously this is pretty subtle but all
adults know what her dad is actually
talking about the beads but we also have
to talk about this pretty inappropriate
moment you can find in Cinderella the
original Cinderella is pretty adorable
with its singing mice and we have to
admit that Jacques and Gus were our
favorites but remember the bead scene
we're not really sure what's happening
but it did make us feel pretty
uncomfortable it gets even worse when
you realize that these are beads it'll
only make sense when you grow up but we
kind of hope you never do
seriously Disney what's with the dirty
jokes cut my cord
but one of the most subtle jokes and
probably the most shocking one comes
from the Rugrats movie it's not a Disney
movie but we just had to sneak it in
because this just proves that no Kid
movie is safe during this world is
something new to me there's a lot of
times when the babies look inside their
diapers Smith says if they cut his cord
but when a keep off looks down and says
consider yourself lucky it might seem
like a totally innocent joke about
cutting the umbilical cord but it's
actually a first joke about cutting
something totally different today
it went unnoticed by the kids or the
adults had a good laugh and that's it
for our video thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]